EVERYTHING KIND OF RUNS THROUGH
HIM.
BUT THIS IS A FAST, POTENTK IN..
SENATORS.S MARK WITH A AFTER
>> Jamie: SIDNEY CROSBY TURNS
GAUDETTE STAYS IN THE PLAY FOR
OTTAWA.
THIS IS THE PUCK THAT MOVED
AROUND.
THE INITIAL PUCK  BY MATT
MURRAY TO KEEP THIS GAME
SCORELESS. OUT.
TAKES A LOOK.
FINDS A FRI
UP.
SLAP SHOT BY ENNIS TRICKLES OFF
A SS
DROPS FREE.
HAS TO BEHAS THIS ONE BANK IN.
DeSMITH WILL LEAVE IT.NDFUL OF "
THAT ARE VERY ACTIVE THAT JUMP
INTO THE PLAY.
AND PITTSBURGH WHACK AT IT.
NOW BROWCE OVER TO
McGINN.
McGINN BACK ACROSS HE PENGUINS'
EBBED.
>> Jamie: STRONG WORK --
END -- DEFENSIVELY BY
OPTION.
IT'S A ROLLINGHIGHLIGHTS WHERE
SIDNEY CROSBY SCORED HIS
500th.SIDNEY CROSBY ROLLS HIS WT
RIGHT THERE.
MATT MURRAY TAKES THE INITIAL
SHOT OFF THECLEAR.
HEINEN WORKING ON THE NEAR SIDE.
OUT OF THE AIR, AND THE EXTRA
EFFORT GETTING IT BY JEFF
CA
BUT JIM RUTHERFORD IS ATH A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY -- PAUL --
WITH A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY BY C. HADN'.
AND THE TURNOVER, CHABOT TR
CORNER.
IN WITH IN.
TURNOVER.
CARTER KNOWS HE'S INOT PROVIDESA
VACANCY FOR OTTAWA. A SHORT STO.
HE SHOTS ARE 25-21.
THERE HAVE BEEN GOOD LOOKS.
IN
ZACH ASTON-REESE SENDS IT IN.
20 SECONDS TO GO.AS BRADY TKACHK
THROWS IT